[MUSIC PLAYING]
The philosopher Eric
Davis refers to humans
as sparks that crackle
with being and intuition.
Right?
There is that sneaking suspicion
that there is more to us
than nature allows.
The human mind lives
in the liminal zone.
It is not bound by time,
by space, and by distance.
There's is a natural
intuition to live
in these spaces of dream.
These spaces
between, so to speak.
We visit these zones when
we're asleep every night.
The dream is real
when you're in it,
Chris Nolan says in inception.
Noam Chomsky talks about
psychic continuity, right?
When we watch a
piece of film that
is 24 still images per second,
and then you introduce editing,
and cutting, and cross-cutting
across time, across space, yet
psychic continuity links
the events together
and creates a
contiguous experience.
The human mind has no problem
orienting it's awareness
towards dimensions in which
time is no longer linear.
We enter these virtual
realities-- well really they're
real virtualities--
and we believe them.
We actively metabolize belief.
We become immersed.
The mind unplugs from
the body and is not
bound in any capacity.
And that eventually
I think is where
we're going to go with
all of our virtual reality
technologies.
We're going to move
towards universals
of our own construction,
as McKenna says.
We're going to move into
spaces in which reality
is going to be a relative term.
Where people might suffer from
relativity sickness the way
that they suffer from ADD today.
It's a wild idea.
I think that's
where we're heading.
[MUSIC PLAYING]